And parents,
man,
they've got to stop putting their kids on video.
We've got to stop.
It's enough you say that,
but there's a little kid that's like six years old at reviews toys and he makes
$20 million a year.
Just looking at toys.
[inaudible] bucks.
I'll open up a box of you know toys.
I'll do it.
100 beans.
That's it.
Nobody wants to see you open up.
[inaudible] not a baby.
I'm going to find something else.
You want to see little cute kids in a diaper?
What?
How's this all going to help?
Ah,
fuck.
I'm gonna find another,
I got to find another thing to make money.
I find another angle.
Yeah,
that kid.
He's making a lot of money on.
Be the youtube toy guy.
There's a lady who does it with just her hands.
A grown woman.
What did she do with her hands?
She opens things up.
Same thing for hands.
I don't know if they're beautiful.
I don't know if their feet out and start using it for her feet to do.
I'm going to open children's toys and my feet.
Is that weird?
No,
you should do.
You should do it and see which one gets better views.
Do it with you with painted toenails and doing deal with kind of like neglected
toenail toenail.
You know what I'm saying?
Like little chips in your paint.
You know this is on Saturday than a neglected toenail.
It's also kind of hot because it's Kinda check.
They'll take some chances like shit.
She's like,
bitch doesn't even have her toenails in order.
She'll,
she lives,
she'll move with you across the country.
She's crawling parking lots.
What's she doing?
Enter into a bank robbing scheme with you taking care of herself.
She's got chip toenails first.
That's a bitch who puts people first.
She toenail check.
Just can't get it together.
Some people just never quite get it together,
right?
Yeah.
And then you see their toes and it's a reflection of their own downfalls.
They're their own worst enemy,
or they have a job or too busy,
too busy mom with a job in a couple of kids who's got time to do nails then
unless you,
you know,
you're a rich white yourself,
you can do them yourself.